Then why does Matthew 21:11 say Jesus is
a prophet? He's more than just a
prophet. Does Jesus ever explicitly say
he's God? No. Does Jesus ever say,
"Worship me?" No. And in Luke 6:12,
Jesus prays all night to God. Why would
God pray all night to himself? Jesus was
showing his human side. In John 11:41,
Jesus says he doesn't do the miracles by
himself. Now, she lied. So now, let's go
for her burial. Matthew 20:11, right?
He's a prophet. Okay. Luke 6:12, right?
Let's go into the burial. Let's do this.
Brutus, you guys ready to learn? Here's
the
article. Matthew 21:11, right? Okay.
Jesus Christ, Israel's
ani wahoo. She said Matthew 21:11,
right? Let's go here. Matthew 21:11,
right? Let's go here. Get ready now.
Here you go. This is what she quoted.
Matthew 21:9-11 14:16. And the crowds
that went before him and that follow him
shouted, "Hosana to the son of David.
Blessed is he who comes in the name of
the Lord. Hosana in the highest." And
when he entered Jerusalem, all the city
was stirred, saying, "Who is this?" And
the crowd said, "This is the prophet
Jesus from Nazareth of Galilee." Now,
number one, did you notice the
inconsistency and dishonesty of this
woman? Did you see the dishonesty and
consistency? She goes, "Did Jesus ever
say, "I'm God or worship me?" But then
she says Matthew 21:11 said Jesus is a
prophet. But notice
guys, Jesus didn't say he's a prophet.
The people said he's a prophet.
So why is
it she demands that Jesus says I am God
or worship me to believe it but doesn't
demand that Jesus say I am a prophet to
accept the fact he's a prophet. Why does
she then accept the testimony of others
and believe what others said about
Jesus? Why the inconsistency?
Why the
inconsistency? Do you catch it, guys? Or
no, you didn't catch it. Learn. May the
spirit illuminate us. Open our eyes to
see through the eyes of the spirit. Open
our ears, the ears of our loved ones, my
daughters, and their eyes to see through
the eyes of the spirit and hear the
voice of the holy spirit. Draw out all
other voices. Enslave, transform in love
with the voice of our God, the father,
son, holy spirit in Jesus
name. Why the
inconsistency? So, did you catch it? She
goes, "Did Jesus say I am God or worship
me?" But in Matthew 21:11, it says he's
a prophet. But wait, who said he's a
prophet? Who said that? The people did.
Why didn't she demand that Jesus say
it? Why didn't she demand that Jesus say
it? Why did she accept the testimony of
others? So now you'll accept the
testimony of others. What others say
about Jesus? because you just accepted
this testimony that Jesus is a prophet.
Now I want to bury you. This is why
we're going to do a lot in the series if
you're
listening. All
right. Arctic Bob is really getting
excited. He likes to chime in a lot. I
don't know. Okay. Now guys understand
once she
acknowledges and accepts what others say
about Jesus it's
burial why let's go here now remember
the
principle if you'll accept the testimony
of
others about Jesus because she quoted
Matthew 21:11 testimony of others that
said he's the prophet then you're now
going to have to accept the testimony of
his own followers who said that he's God
and worshiped him as
such. You with me
there? Here we go. You
ready? John 20:27:29 Then he said to
Thomas, "Bring your finger here and see
my hands, and bring your hand here and
put it into my side, and do not be
unbelieving, but believing." Thomas
answered and said to him, "My Lord and
my God." Now, did Jesus rebuke him?
Jesus said to him, "Because you have
seen me, have you believed? Blessed are
those who do not sin and yet believe."
So now, Lily, since you accepted the
crowd's testimony that he's the prophet,
now you're damned because Jesus's
disciple, an eyewitness of Christ, who
saw Christ alive physically after dying
for our sins, worships him as his Lord
and God. And the Greek is very explicit.
It's the Lord of me and the God of me
and Jesus blesses those who will
acknowledge and believe that Christ is
the risen Lord who's alive and that
Christ is their God. See it now watch
the Greek though. You guys really want
me to take my time and go in depth,
right? You don't mind if I go in depth
then? Here you go. Let's go here. John
20:28.
No matter what you
do. What does it say? What does the
Greek
say? Well, what does that mean right
here? Look at it. It's literally said to
Jesus, "The God of me, the Lord of me,
the God of me." You are the Lord of me
and you are the God of me. Oops, Lily,
you got buried. How about here? What did
Paul say about Jesus? What did he call
Jesus? Let's see. Ready? Titus
2:13-4. Looking for the blessed hope and
the appearing of the glory of our great
God and Savior Jesus Christ. So he's not
only our God and Savior, he's our great
God and Savior, Jesus Christ. And he is
the God and Savior who gave himself for
us that he might redeem us from all
lawlessness and purify for himself a
people for his own possession zealous
for good works. Now let's see the Greek.
Are you ready for the
Greek? You guys are learning, right? So
I'm not wasting your time. Sometimes I
feel like I'm a boore because I wouldn't
listen to me. I bore myself. Here it is.
Let's see. Titus
2:13. Titus
2:13. There you go. Right here, guys.
Oh, I got too much meat to unpack with
Matthew 21. Now, let's go back
here. Awaiting the blessed hope and the
appearing. Now, you don't even need to
read Greek, but it translates it for
you. Tis
doxis to mealoo. Do you guys would you
say it meal or megaloo? Anyway, it's not
our God, great God. It's the great
God. The great God and Savior of us,
Christ
Jesus. The great God and Savior of us,
Jesus. See it?
Thomas says Jesus is the Lord of me and
the God of me. And Paul says Christ is
the great God and Savior of
us. Say it. All right. What about Peter?
What does Peter say? No matter what you
do, he says the same thing. Second Peter
1:1.
Simon Peter, a slave and apostle of
Jesus Christ to those who have received
the same kind of faith as ours. God has
given you the same gift of faith. He has
enabled you, energize you by the spirit
that you've accepted to have the same
faith in the same object, same trust in
the same object.
And this gift of faith was given to
Gentiles and Jews equally to all
believers equally because of the justice
because that Christ is impartial. He's
unbiased. He doesn't love the Jews more
than the Gentiles. He loves all
creatures equally and he loves all
believers equally. So he is unbiased and
impartial and wants to love and bless
all of you equally.
However, the Lord blesses those who obey
more and sin less. So, the only bias
that Christ will show is towards those
who sin less and love him more because
the more you love him, the more
blessings and rewards. That's just
natural. Even with parents, they love
all their kids equally. But when one
kid, right, is more respectful than the
other, the kid who's more respectful
gets more
rewards, more
opportunities than the rebellious kid
who gets more
punishment. It's not because the parent
loves one kid more than the other. In
point of fact, when it comes to
parenting, you guys know the troubled
kid is the one who gets more attention
from the parents, right?
Those of you who have troubled children,
you know it's actually the troubled
children that get more of your attention
and time because you realize they need
it more than the well-behaved child
because that troubled child is the one
that's more dangerous and likely to do
something
harmful. You get it?
You with me there? So the Lord Jesus
loves all the children of God equally.
He loves his daughters. The father loves
his daughters as much as his sons. And
he wants to bless all of you equally and
exalt all of you equally. But he's a
heavenly father and he's the perfect
father and he rewards your behavior or
disciplines you like a good father. So
the more you obey, the less you sin, the
greater reward. The more you sin, the
more you rebel, the greater your
discipline.
You want me
there? Everyone got
it? And like a good parent will be more
concerned with the
troubled
child, the one who's prone to harm
himself or herself and do something
destructive. And so they focus more on
that child. because they fear for that
child. The same is with God.